i could you imagine dragons in the uk
they would they they have like 10
[ __ ] minutes introducing each other
before they even actually start the
[ __ ] pitch
business cards
the person pitching would have to go and
[ __ ] pour in water and everything
like it's like they can't even start and
oh my god
jesus they'd have to start with like a
board meeting or something before they
could even get in the room could you
imagine they they that
people being pitched would be like no we
know exactly what's happening i want to
see the script of the man pitching
before he pitches it you know it's like
insane
i would love to see it actually but what
i never understood about those shows is
that it's it's just like
it's sold as you know it's these are
very real businesses and very real ideas
that some of them actually go on to be
successful and stuff right but like you
you look at some of the people going on
and you're just like okay i've watched
dragons then before or like shark tank
which is the american version right it's
there's there's like a very simple
formula there's like very specific
questions that all the dragons ask every
single [ __ ] time
and somehow 90 of the contestants never
know their [ __ ] numbers like i think
surely that's the first thing you do if
you if you figure out you're going on
dragons denver you're like all right let
me just figure out my [ __ ] profit
margins yeah that's literally the first
thing you should do yeah like what's
your gross like sorry about it
i'm not gross thank you very much
they're like they're like what is your
target audience or whatever they'll be
like i don't know people
[Music]
people with money like i saw this ford
clip but it may be [ __ ] laughing from
the british one
it's from the guy who's like the worst
he's like so what is he called is he
called tuka tuka
sounds like a breaking bad character
yeah right he's like he's like the guy
who like all the other dragons hate on
the road
and uh it's just a great moment he is
he's pitching the offer to them he's
like okay so i'm gonna give you the
fifty thousand pounds you asked for i've
seen this for for ninety percent of the
business what and then the dragons were
like so all of the business so you said
you're trying to buy the business off of
it
like what's the remaining ten percent
you can't do anything
i remember so so like the first thing he
was pitching to was like sweat
so who are you giving the money to and
he's like i'm giving the money to the
business and he was like but you own 90
percent of the business
so you're giving the money to yourself
it was so good and all the other dragons
were like what the [ __ ] bro
what the [ __ ] is this
ultimate money laundering
but imagine if you got to accept you're
like sharp dragon shut up this is genie
he's gonna agree to it
oh my god it's like
like what is this like these supposed to
be professional like cause half these
sometimes you see the dragons right
you're like you're not a [ __ ] good
businessman you just got really [ __ ]
lucky with one business and managed to
convince this [ __ ] tv show to let you
off yeah some of them have no [ __ ]
idea what they're doing i swear
they'll be like they'll be like yeah
he's got a multi-million dollar business
then when you think about businesses
multi-million dollar business is
actually not that difficult no it's yeah
because it's it's it's so stark the
contrast between like shark tank and
dragon's den dragon like shark tank have
like mark cuban and like full-on like
[ __ ] billionaires really really
really really like really really simple
people yeah super super [ __ ] wealthy
and then compared to like the dragons
it's
it's i think half the dragons are like
pretty successful but yeah they've had
trouble like keeping the seats filled
right and they always bring in people
and a lot of the time they've had like
businesses they just sold and made like
four million which is obviously a [ __ ]
ton of money and don't get me wrong but
we're talking businesses you know it's
not really a good in the business well
four million is nothing no
i wouldn't say it's a hardcore proven
track record that you know how to run a
business hundred percent you know what i
mean yeah
all right you might have got lucky here
and there you had a good idea it's like
it doesn't prove that you i don't think
that's good enough where you can go on
and start telling people how to run
their businesses you know what i mean
like personally yeah i get it i get it i
i was just kind of like all right okay
all right they've introduced them like
he made two million dollars off his
online card business and i'm like
what what is that
what that's that's never even heard of
it that's hardly a business
oh how am i kidding i'm insulting them
two million dollars
child's play i don't know i just when
you when you you know we're talking a
lot of businesses here that's that's not
that's not that much in business terms
well yeah in the business world it's not
that much yeah yeah yeah in layman's
terms it is
well yeah i think that's how the show
works is that so most people watching
the the show in the uk obviously a
million pounds
two million pounds that's [ __ ] insane
yeah most people can't comprehend that
yeah but you know when you work with
some businesses and stuff and you
understand the margins they're working
with that's that's not that much
but i guess it doesn't matter it's tv at
the end of the day they're not actually
trying to like it's not actually trying
to give good business but it's like a
[ __ ] tv
yeah if they did people would know what
like a [ __ ] their net profit is and
their margins are yeah i swear some of
the british ones are like staged i they
must
no way some of the stuff because there's
one time there there's like a pyramid
scheme come on
on the british tv show like a guy came
in
who just advertised a ponzi scheme right
and they were like this actually yeah
and the dragons are like this sounds
awfully a lot like a pyramid scheme